all right well summer is here for Clark
County School students the question is
well what can they do now well plenty of
Summer Camps still have space available
including the YMCA so don't worry if you
waited until the last minute Candace
Charles joining us at the Y in
Centennial hills to explore some of the
fun Candace good morning
good morning to good morning folks yes
right now I'm in the wonderful huge pool
you can see there are big slides over
there for the kiddos to enjoy when they
come out to summer camp lots of fun
options and I'm hanging out in the pool
with Erica Segal the Youth and Family
director so much joining me right now
appreciate it tell us a little bit about
what an average day is like and the
options I hear they also get meals yes
so summer camp here around 7 A.M to 6
p.m lunch and an afternoon snack is
included in that day we're going to have
a jam-packed day full of fun so Games
songs adventure activities fun at our
outdoor water park stem Arts and
Humanities anything that you can think
of we try and include that here in our
summer camp options and I know you guys
started registration fairly early April
right and some of the members they got
the first dibs on it but you guys have
spots open still right how easy is it to
register yes we do have spots open at
all four of our YMCA locations very easy
to register just go to our website lost
Vegas ymca.org or stop into any one of
our four locations and we'll get you all
set up and registered all right sounds
simple enough thank you so much Erica
you guys have fun this summer it's all
kicking off on May 30th runs until
August 4th it's 162 per week per child
for the 5 to 15 for preschoolers they
have a preschool program as well 172
dollars so so much fun lots of fun
activities and of course a lot of the
details for you on our website
newsnow.com for now live at the Y in
Centennial hills off of Buffalo I'm
Candace Charles 8 News Now